as residents in Thousand Oaks California
grapple with the danger from that huge
wildfire
they are also struggling with a deadly
attack on a bar that left a dozen people
and the gunman dead authorities are
investigating whether the gunman
believed his former girlfriend would be
at the bar Carter Evans reports federal
agents were back at 28-year old Ian
Long's house and clearing the crime
scene as they search for clues as to why
the former Marine opened fire in the
border line bar killing 12 with an
extended magazine on a Glock handgun and
according to the Ventura County
Sheriff's Department posting on
Instagram in between shots
Todd Stratton was there Wednesday night
I had it in my head the whole time about
how the profile of it mass shooter is
you know certain categories and now you
find out it's your friend and it's my
friend and it doesn't fit because I know
this person he'd been friends with long
for 11 years and he says he thought long
might be suffering from PTSD when he
came back from deployment in Afghanistan
in 2013 and there was times where people
would ask him about it and he got kind
of you know upset and told her like he
doesn't you know like talking about it
however Long's high school track coach
says he showed a violent and abusive
side even before he entered the Marines
I was talking to some students and their
eyes got wide and I turned around and
Ian had been standing behind me with his
hand like this being funny funny and I
remember yelling at him being like are
you kidding me
among Long's victims were college
students veterans and others who were at
borderline for country-western dancing
on college night many inside had already
survived one mass shooting at the route
91 Harvest Festival in Las Vegas 13
months ago including Danny Merrill I
thought was get out get safe get as many
people safe as you can
and I was just telling me oh man like I
can't do this again I don't want to do
this again no one should have to do it
once let alone do it twice country music
fan Brendan Kelly also lived through the
Vegas massacre he was on the borderline
dance floor when the shots rang out it's
definitely harder because I didn't know
anyone specifically at around anyone but
he did know people here and some of his
friends didn't make it out this time for
CBS this morning Saturday Carter Evans
Los Angeles can't believe some of these
people have to live through that again
again yeah